so today the start of another 48 Hours
strike called by the rmt union however
we have learned that another Union the
twsa has agreed to an offer from Network
rail does that give you encouragement
that a deal may be closer in these rail
disputes and a resolution could be on
the card soon
well it's absolutely critical that a
deal is found obviously this is causing
a lot of disruptions people trying to
travel around it's also causing worries
for Hospitality businesses but Libra
understands the strength of feeling here
we've seen the longest squeeze on real
wages for a very long period and the
most intense one actually in living
memory recently and I have to see these
strikes do reflect an appalling failure
from the conservative government we've
only seen at the 11th Hour any
engagement from government ministers for
example in the real dispute Libra's been
calling for months from ministers to get
a grip on this to actually make sure
that a deal happens because all of the
cards for that ultimately were in the
government's hands they're the ones who
set the Mandate for the train operating
companies and yet for months they
refused to get involved in trying to get
a deal and with nurses we've actually
seen the government saying well they're
not going to talk about the very issue
that the nurses say they want to
negotiate on so the responsibility for
this I'm afraid does lie with Rishi
sunak it lies with this government which
seems to have frankly given up on
governing instead we need to have a
labor government that can start to fix
these issues deal with these problems
not a government that seems to be just
walking off the pitch okay well we'll
talk about the nurses dispute in just a
moment the government no doubt would
argue well look we've got to deal with
the TSA Union
um so they would say that they are
making progress there but as far as the
rail strikes are concerned are you
comfortable with the fact that unions
will be striking over Christmas
well of course this is going to cause
disruption to people there's no question
about that it is going to be disrupting
people's plans but industrial action is
only ever a last resort obviously
workers lose pay when they engage in
that action and it indicates that
negotiations have not been taking place
in the way that they should have done
now yes of course it's positive that
government ministers finally have seen
the need for this but we didn't have a
single second of Engagement from
government ministers on this issue
around the rail strikes until very very
late in the day in fact just over the
last few hours that is not good enough
when we knew this dispute has been in
place for five months and the
conservatives have done literally
nothing to try and resolve it with all
the pain and problem that it's causing
to people
so what would labor do should nurses get
a better settlement
well what we would do and what we are
very clear about seeking and what we did
indeed in government and we didn't have
a single NHS strike under labor
governments what we would do is we would
negotiate we wouldn't be doing what the
conservatives have done you know
yesterday they sent one of their health
ministers out on the airwaves precisely
to say that they wouldn't negotiate for
example you would negotiate but with
what's in mind sorry to interrupt
Unleashed sorry I just wonder we haven't
got a huge amount of time but would you
be offering them a higher settlement
we would be talking with them about the
right settlement to be reached one that
works for public finances that works for
the Health Service that works for
patients and that works for the staff
within it I'm not going to pluck a
figure out of the air on live television
that doesn't do the process Justice
because it's got to be a genuine
negotiation but I'm not asking you to
give me a figure I'm afraid from the
government well really this is I'm not
asking to give a figure but we know
what's being offered we know what
inflation is would you give a higher
offer to them
well we would be sitting down with them
and working this through and that's why
as I say I'm not going to on live
television pluck a figure out of there
that wouldn't do the process Justice it
wouldn't do the NHS Justice the workers
in it justice or indeed patients and
we've not seen any of that engagement as
I said from government ministers you
know we didn't even see a government
Minister sitting down with the RCN for
months they had the whole of the summer
when the nurses warned that they were
going to be thinking about this kind of
action unless there was engagement they
did absolutely nothing and now we have
these conservative strikes I'm afraid
the Rishi sunak strikes and they're
Steve Barkley strikes okay and the
government says that it's honoring the
recommendations of the pay review body
the nurses Union argues that the picture
has changed a great deal since its
conclusions and inflation is much higher
so do you think that the pay review body
should look again at the recommend
foundations
there's government that sets the
parameters for these bodies to operate
within and you now have even newspapers
that traditionally would be viewed as on
the rights of Center conservative senior
politicians even from their own side
saying that actually the government
needs to be sitting down and negotiating
around these issues which is important
you've made very clearly but what about
the pay review body should they look
again at the recommendations that
they've put out
well if that needs to be a part of the
negotiation then it needs to be
discussed and I think the problem is
that the conservative government have
started from a position of saying they
will not talk with nurses about the
critical issues for them and let's be
clear this isn't just about pay it's
also because nurses are overworked
they're burnt out their words are
understaffed labor set out a plan for
massively boosting our Health Service
you know scrapping and on tax exemption
using that money to increase the volume
of nurses speedily bring more into our
hospitals into our Healthcare settings
you know again the government isn't
delivering on that either and I'm afraid
it's patients who are paying the price
as a result of this